[Music]
guys remember when shah killed garma
remember when sasuke left the village
remember when frieza destroyed planet
vegeta
guys there are a few things in life that
hurt more than a knife in your back
twisted by the hand of a friend an anime
betrayal you might say
now funny enough anime betrayals are not
limited just to animate we have our fair
share of treachery
here in esports as well and we figured
why not rank them
this is the kind of stuff that's going
to make you say
now before we start the list proper guys
understand that we're having a little
bit of fun with this one
and at the end of the day we're all
friends in esports
remember that before you flame us in the
comment section now let's get on with it
with the top 10 anime betrayals in
esports
kicking off our list at number 10 is the
original conductor of the korean hype
train
monte cristo
league of legends fans know all too well
that monty is no stranger to betrayals
but the south korean loyalist shocked
fans of the 2017
overwatch world cup with his ultimate
anime plan
leading to this roller coaster of
emotions i spent five
years of my life living in south korea
and i loved it but today you know what
i'm going to be what a swerve
i did not expect this you know people
have been wanting me
to cheer for america for years to
protect the americans
this is one of my top 10 anime
portrayals
you know what golden boy today's not
that day
no what there it is
oh no this is a double turn
a heel turn one of us it's
korea baby
now we just couldn't make a list of
anime betrayals without it featuring
eternal
envy which is why he comes in at number
nine on our list
the funny thing is like no matter how
much you play with someone i don't feel
like i truly will ever understand them
you know if there isn't that surprise or
any like
things that are like unexpected
happening it will be really boring as
well
ee can be described as a compulsive
kicker with an anime-grade desire to win
which would explain the recurring theme
of betrayal throughout his dota career
so fnatic did what many believed to be
the riskiest thing an organization could
possibly do at the time
they gave the reigns to eternal envy
don't do this it's done helmsman
signal the fleet and take us out of
orbit after he was kicked from no
tidehunter early in his career
ee would go on to assemble his own
rosters to compete for the coveted aegis
of champions
with a number of different orcs despite
being kicked from the team he created
envy never gave up but year after year
envy would cycle through players on
questionable terms
regardless of their individual
performances which often left a feeling
of bitterness and betrayal
within the dota 2 community at least i
wasn't kicked by envy
[Music]
look guys we know how much some of you
hate fortnite but this was just
way too funny to leave off our list
which is why it takes the number 8 spot
after humiliating ninja dr lupo agrees
to help his brother in arms
or at least that's what ninja thought
say my name
then what happened
say the right name daddy
please that's right that's right
look at this come on man stop it dude
i only have that was all the what i have
left to repair that
i only have one left
it's fault you get you gonna get it
there you go man are you gonna get it
yeah no you only won
coming in at number seven is a tale of
two swedish comrades
leffen was villainized by the community
early on in his career for what many
claimed was toxic behavior
but the young phenom always trusted that
his fellow countryman armada
would have his back but after a
disappointing placement at apex 2013
leffen returned home to a shocking truth
armada had been collecting evidence
against him that would eventually lead
to a six-month fan from the european
smash community
armada had knew known about it and like
while i was coaching him on stage and
stuff like that he's been like trying to
ban me
the whole time so at that time i felt
pretty betrayed after training
traveling and playing together for years
the last thing leffen expected was for
his close friend and fellow countrymen
to have been plotting against him which
let's be honest is anime as hell
leffen has since reformed and made up
with armada wrapping up this anime
betrayal with a wholesome ending fit for
a disney movie
honestly like at this point i have at
least forgiven harmonic i don't think
it's gonna give me anything to like keep
hating him or like disliking him we can
kind of look back at us you know like oh
we were still a teenager like we're all
going for it
we've kind of moved on
clg versus tsm is a classic north
american rivalry in league of legends
and one that doublelift is certainly no
stranger to
after leading clg to an nalcs title and
world's birth in 2015
the announcement that he would be
leaving the team he started his career
on shocked the league community like
this is a team that i agree with and i
was committed to grow with for
forever but the sad thing is like
honestly they weren't committed back
feeling betrayed by his old support
aphromoo doublelift publicly stated that
the
two were no longer buddies are you and
afros still buddies
no not really the truth is afro went to
the org
and he said it's either me or him i feel
like he'd give up on me as a friend and
as a teammate
back see one without the other
isn't any good oh oh i knew he was going
to do that
the plot thickened when he announced the
team that he'd be joining
hey my name is doublelift and starting
today
i'll be a part of tsm but the betrayals
didn't end there
after a few middling worlds performances
doublelift was released from tsm like
they kicked me off of ts or they kicked
me off of
clg and there and then
they never really found success again i
hope tsm kicks me off
and they never find success again
honestly i do
doublelift would have his revenge after
joining team liquid as he led them to
worlds while both tsm and clg
missed out on the biggest tournament of
the year
coming in at number five is a
continuation of the na dota saga of
backstabs
this time focusing on aui 2000 story
after he was kicked from cloud9 by
eternal envy in 2015 aui joined evil
geniuses
and helped them tear through the
international as their support but
despite dominating the competition and
helping eg become the first north
american team to win the multi-million
dollar tournament
they kicked him from their roster
shortly thereafter
i don't know if it hit me that we won
ti-5 just because i never really
had time to take a vacation um
everything
for like the next couple weeks was just
too surreal and then
the first major changes
if kicking a player who helped win the
international six
days after hoisting the aegis isn't an
epic anime betrayal
well we don't know what is i want a ti
after that
still got kicked though
n a dota saga of anime betrayals
continues
yet again in our number four entry but
this time we'll be telling the tale
of arteezy at this point we'd just be
repeating ourselves but
intertwined in the story of aui was
arteezy who went back and forth between
eg
and secret four times in two years
our tour has been kind of like the team
hopper he left and then
he came back and then he left again and
i think both times was like very
devastating
i wasn't totally surprised but i was
more so disappointed
so it was like very frustrating for us
to lose him because we were you know
scrambling with like how are we going to
replace a player like our tour and
the second one was i was very the second
one was [ __ ] to be honest
it was really stupid i was very very
upset i was pissed
how's it feel to be back to eg for the
third time well it feels okay to be back
in eg
uh actually this is hard to answer man
oh my god talk about a double agent
[Music]
betrayals aren't always intentional and
coming in at number three is the time
that tabe probably
almost definitely leaked invictus
gaming's secret strats
during an analyst death segment at
worlds 2015.
seriously just look how quickly xyrene
tries to change the subject
i'm a good friend of ig's coach and he
told me that they have secret weapon
insider info tommy he told me that uh
cacao
maybe we're choosing hacrum or lee sin
jungling
and he said they are going to pick
kalista and cannonbot
and well so now everybody listening is
just going to ban those out
but what if that's the what if that's
the plan what if they ban those out
there
you're throwing everybody no i'm just
kidding there's also other one
other two secret weapon is this let's
not give away all their secret weapons
in the end invictus gaming would go on
to employ these same strategies that
tabe said they would
and spoiler alert the strats did not
work out
tabi was right everyone tell me what's
wrong hq probably didn't have enough
time to listen
so nothing given away but the nexus
falls ahq
even out the matchup here and ig look
all over the place
[Music]
look guys astralis may be the best cs go
team of all time but that doesn't
exclude them from the struggles
of betrayal in early 2018 kiarby left
the team just before he was supposed to
renew his contract which is why he comes
in
at number two on our list all right so
let's talk a little bit about the great
northern betrayal
he was supposed to go on a skiing
vacation and everything and then like
it started continuing a little bit i
can't remember how many days it were but
suddenly it was like it was so obvious
i can't remember who it was call his dad
and he said he was sick with the flu and
we're like can you please tell us if
he's gonna sign or not
it was a hard decision but i think it
definitely was
the right decision career wise for me
there was a lot of hard feelings
i don't think we wanted him to have any
success with north
ultimately it made us better i still
feel like we can get a good relationship
out of it but
it's just yeah it's just sad to feel
betrayed
in some way
taking the title for the ultimate anime
betrayal is the story of fly and no tail
it's like a great anime battle you know
like [ __ ]
like oh man like whenever sasuke
betrayed naruto
og was a roster built on trust and
friendship
the duo won a number of majors together
but could never perform when it mattered
most
at the international after a year of
dominance
i got crushed then just months before ti
relations were severed in a move that
shocked the world the team
built up on friendship and love had a
split
that nobody saw coming flying s4 why did
you leave og
the team hasn't worked for a long time
uh and i can say personally that i lost
a lot of motivation
when the whole situation arised where i
could
join eg i felt a new surge of motivation
where i felt like this is really a team
i could win with i'm actually not that
willing to talk about it
yeah it's something for later
another day it's just personal it's
nobody's business
right i can just say that the way it
happened was
was not nice uh towards the
ones that were left behind and in true
anime form fly and no tail were destined
to meet
on opposing teams at the tia upper
bracket curse from the hotel comes down
to the three in the tops and
deep in out of it they'll hang on
they'll take him into the snowball they
want to keep this fight going they're
going to talk
they'll take down the egg they'll find
the egg that pokes
[Applause]
[Applause]
but this is one anime betrayal with a
happy ending having defeated his former
friends and teammates no tail took a
rookie star and former coach
all the way to hoist the aegis of
champions
ain't got nothing
[Applause]
well guys that's our list of the top 10
anime betrayals in esports now if you
want more content like this
you already know what to do hit the
subscribe button tap that like button
and don't forget to comment below now
let me just say i'm so glad that we here
at the score esports
value our trust and our friendship
enough
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button